( intro music )
( applause )
Hey. Good evening.
Get your passports,
if you don't have with you
then just lay low in the boat
and we're gonna cross
from Congo to Cameroon.
This is one of the last pristine
wilderness in the world.
So, we're entering
into this forest.
One of the largest snake
on record is on this picture.
This is the forest floor,
what you've just seen
from outside.
Can you find the snake?
If you find it,
you're my guest, you know,
for a beer after the lecture.
So where is the snake?
It's very hard to find.
It's up here.
I didn't touch the snake,
I just went above.
And here you see the head
and the body it just disappears
in the leaves.
It's a huge animal.
( audience gasping )
It's the Gaboon Viper.
It's the snake which injects
the most amount of venom,
a spoonful,
and has the longest fang,
up to two inches long.
( audience gasping )
so, you definitely don't want to
get bitten by one of these.
And you know, globally
a 100,000 people die
from snakebite
and the only reason
why they're dying
because there is no
antivenom.
We have the perfect technology
to make antivenom
but there is just no
money in some of these
tropical countries.
So 100,000 people
die from snakebite.
But let's go back.
Let's come back from Africa
here to the US.
And, this is Chicago.
And we're gonna go to the
South Side of Chicago.
University of Chicago Hospital.
This patient
just suffered a heart attack
the night before.
And his life has been saved
by this snake.
This snake is a
Pygmy Rattlesnake,
the source of a
top heart attack medication.
In the US, out of the top three
heart attack medications
two of them are coming
from snake venoms.
So, it's a huge, huge impact.
Other than this two medication
we have 20 different medicines
coming from animal venoms
for high blood pressure,
for cardiac failure,
for cancer and HIV pain,
top drug for diabetes.
But still in nature
we have 20 million toxins
left unstudied,
in different spiders,
scorpions and so on.
So, again it's not only snakes,
it's sea anemones,
different sort of fishes,
amphibians,
even some primates
have toxic secretions.
So what we do as pharmacologist
is we collect all of these
venomous creatures
from all over the world,
we gather their toxins
and we create toxin libraries,
and we screen that out of
this massive toxin libraries
which one is the best match
for a target in the human body
because that can be
a potential future medication.
So, in the next few minutes
just bear with me
and I'm going to show you
what it takes
to go around the world and
collect these toxins
because actually the least risky
of the whole trip
is catching the snake.
( audience laughter )
So, this is the airport in Fiji
we landing and at least
somebody is waiting for us.
( audience laughter )
But sometimes we do end up
in the wrong island.
And you know, here, you know,
my helper and I, you know,
we find human skulls
instead of snake eggs
what we were looking for.
This is in the Arabian desert
at the
Saudi Arabia-Yemen border.
And if you follow the news
you know that
Yemen is not really a safe place
to travel.
So I ended up in a military camp
and rented Ahmed.
This is Ahmed, my bodyguard.
And he keeps an eye on me,
you can see him,
you know,
he's keeping an eye on me.
And in exchange
I had to fed him with Khat,
which is a local narcotic
just to keep him high.
( audience laughter )
But...
what we did...
of course he was
watching my back,
but also what we did, we showed
pictures for the locals,
you know,
asking have you seen this snake
and so on.
You see a very prominent
presence of the AK-47
( audience laughter )
And there are lots of
military checkpoints in Yemen.
So, every time we cross one
they were asking,
"Are you American?"
And I said, "No".
"British?"
"No."
"Australian?"
And once they run
out of countries
I told them I am from Hungary.
Nobody ever heard of Hungary.
( audience laughter )
But, but...
everyone had a Nokia phone.
So, I told him
pop-up the Nokia phone,
because the Nokia
was made in Hungary.
( audience laughter )
So, since there is
not a single person
in the world who doesn't love
his mobile phone,
so I never ever had a problem
after that
at military check points
in Yemen.
( audience laughter )
We are going
a little bit closer to the US,
this is, this was just
a couple of months ago.
The only way to get into
the rain forest,
either you have to fly in
or you take a boat.
As you can see here the
dress code is pretty liberal.
( audience laughter )
And, the TSA is not really
in charge here
because this is a
deadly blowgun.
So this is the Guaraní Indians'
territory at the
Ecuadorian-Peruvian
border zone.
And they're using these blowguns
to hunt for monkeys.
But we ended up actually
traveling with the dead tapir
killed by a jaguar.
And you know,
fall into the water,
was rotting and bloated and
floating on the river.
So, we chopped it up this tapir
and this is how
we continued our trip.
But take a good look
of this engine
because that engine
was gone by the night.
It actually fall into the river.
So, I said, God this is great.
You know, we are in the middle
of the Amazon and you know,
this engine just
falls into this river
and it is as you see it's not
really crystal clear water.
So we were trying to
recover the engine,
couldn't find it,
had to sleep on the river bank.
Next morning
we're trying to get the engine.
We're trying really,
really hard.
It's pretty hopeless
but you know, finally
we actually find it.
And made into the village,
the Guaraní village
along with the tapir
you know, he's cooked.
So the night is coming,
so we've to consider
our options.
And this is the
typical campsites.
So, here is the--
my hotel suite.
This is my bedroom,
this is my study
and the kitchen.
( audience laughter )
I'm not picky.
I really sleep anywhere
you know,
when the night is coming.
Talking about cars,
I like to give ride
for hitchhikers.
This is in Kenya,
the Kenya-Sudan border.
And you can see that this lady,
this Kalenjin lady
she is all smiles here
and she's a little bit concerned
on the right side.
Well, the difference between
the two pictures
that here I informed her that
she is sitting next to
13 vipers.
( audience laughter )
If you have some
surgery background it helps,
you know, to fix the puncture
in remote places in Africa.
And sometimes we do stay
in hotels until we're
being kicked out
because of the snakes.
And here you can see that
this is in Yemen, back to Yemen.
And, just in case, the
AK-47 is standing by.
Alright, so, so we get there
we made friendship
with the locals
and the military.
So let's,
let's look for some snakes.
Well, we have still
other problems
like elephants. This is in the
Congo basin rain forest again.
So, I was standing on
a termite hill
try to take a picture
of this elephant,
was eating the
other part of this bamboo.
Then it came so close,
put up the four feet in
the bottom of the termite hill
and I was thinking,
"God this is the end
of my life."
I mean it was literally like
a few feet from me.
So then my guide
who used to be a poacher
was standing
on the other termite hill
was whispering
something to the elephant.
So then elephant turned away
and now I had courage to take
a picture of his behind.
( audience laughter )
This is in Solomon Islands,
Australia.
The crocodiles are
a big problem.
So this is the crocodile nest.
And the reason why the mother is
just lunging out
because I asked
my field assistant,
that's a technical term
for girlfriend,
to check out
what's happening
in the crocodile nest.
( audience laughter )
So then you get into real
problem when you get
bitten by a snake.
So, I was bitten six
times before.
I had a Spitting Cobra
spat on my face,
venom.
And I am allergic to snake venom
and to the snake antivenom.
This is my last time in Brazil.
Of course I'm in good hands,
you know, the Brazilian ladies,
but...
inside you know, I had all
of this allergic reaction.
Three friends of mine
passed away from snakebites,
so you have to be very careful.
Anyway,
so after all of this risk taking
you are in a position
to catch a snake.
And this is how I did
close to 40 years ago
back in Hungary.
And this is what happened
in Micronesia.
So ladies and gentlemen,
this is the moment
why we traveling.
I'm holding
200 toxins in my hand,
which has never been studied
and we just don't know what
kind of possible medications
can be extracted from it.
And this is how we
get the venom.
We're getting in a form of
a tissue samples,
from the DNA we can recreate
every single toxin,
and then we let the snake go.
Sometimes
I do bring back live snakes
to the US and whenever I tell
the taxicab driver
what I got in the box
those are end up my fastest
rides from JFK to the city.
( audience laughter )
And finally
I mention the toxin libraries.
So what you see here,
this is a designer toxin.
A toxin which came from
a toxin library like that.
And has a promising drug lead
for autoimmune disorders
like multiple sclerosis
and rheumatoid arthritis.
So, this is why we traveling.
So, I'm finishing my talk with
this incredible creatures.
They hold the key
for future medications.
And this is the place
where they live.
This is the home of the snake,
which give a medication,
which is one of the
most successful
in the history of
entire medicine,
treating more than
40 million patients worldwide.
This is the Iguazu Falls.
So, next time when you go here
remember that behind this beauty
you have these
incredible creatures
and they can save your life.
Thank you.
( applause )
( outro music )